batman is finally living up to the
detective part of detective comics in
the new movie the batman directed by
matt reeves and starring robert
pattinson as a caped crusader fans of
the classic dc character are introduced
to a new version of bruce wayne the film
opens with a brutal murder revealing
that there is a new serial killer on the
rampage in gotham city aiming to expose
the lives of corrupt public officials
meanwhile a thriving illegal business
circulating drugs called drops is run by
carmine falcone and oswald cobblepot aka
the penguin and bruce is caught in the
middle of it all trying to help save her
city and the people in it a lot of the
characters in the movie are very
familiar to fans including selena kyle
aka catwoman james gordon and alfred
pennyworth but there are also some
striking changes in the batman compared
to other screen adaptations of the
superhero story in this case the biggest
change comes in the form of batman's
goals and everyday behavior in the
batman bruce truly takes on the role of
detective looking closely at all of the
clues laid out by the riddler in order
to catch him
i've been trying to reach you
in the batman the defining difference
between this version of bruce wayne and
any other we've seen on the big screen
is that pattinson's batman is more
detective-like than ever before although
he's still a vigilante who uses
technology and his fist to beat up the
expected criminals on the street he also
understands that careful observation and
investigation can get him far especially
when it comes to the riddler the riddler
is the main antagonist of the film and
he is introduced through the murder of
mayor don mitchell jr bruce shows up
alongside the police officers and
detectives of gotham city to the crime
scene called there by gordon well one
main reason gordon calls him there is
likely the letter addressed to the
batman left by the body it's probably
also due to bruce's talent in taking
notice of the details and tracking down
criminals for example bruce quickly
takes note of a key piece of evidence
nearby the blood spatter on the ground
from the carpeting tool with the users
as a murder weapon at this point it
looks like the investigative team hasn't
even spotted it yet themselves as a
crime scene photographer notes his
actions and photographs the blood after
bruce moves away bruce brings gordon
along early on to the mayor's car where
he finds a usb drive at the rid of the
left containing evidence of his shady
dealings at the club he also finds a
note in the riddler's apartment hidden
in the back cage all on his own overall
bruce clearly understands the value of
intelligence and patience particularly
getting into the detective mindset as he
tracks down the riddler who challenges
him through the constant riddles as
clues seriously bruce is surprisingly
skilled at riddles showcasing reeves
decision to emphasize bruce's mental
strength alongside his physical
capabilities
justice
the answer's justice although bruce
spends a lot of the batman fighting
criminals on the street he is actively
investigating the crimes of the riddler
kabul part falcone and the corrupt
officials riddler brings to light in
this investigation gordon is arguably
his right-hand man and the police
detective clearly respects bruce's
abilities and drive for justice at one
point in the film he even says that
bruce is the only one he trusts
representing his unwavering loyalty to
the vigilante whose real identity he
doesn't even know the two connects to
the bat signal when bruce needs to go
out and fight criminals on a
particularly rough night but also when
they have some important information to
share with one another usually bruce
provides gordon with all the new
information he finds though he kind of
jumps a gun in the case of the riddler
even enacting an undercover scheme with
selena at the club without telling
gordon likely because it's more personal
than other cases gordon in the batman is
not too different from other iterations
of the character in that he values truth
and justice over violence and vengeance
though there does seem to be some leeway
for him here as he looks the other way a
bit allowing batman to rough up some
criminals here and there but all in all
it's bruce's just nature that convinces
gordon to keep working with him on cases
and considering he literally brings a
vigilante to a crime scene he clearly
values bruce's detective abilities
unlike some people
how am i part of this
oh you're really not as smart as i
thought you were
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the batman are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]